on his team now lebron  36 years of age 18th year has the  basketball  15 to shoot lakers lead by one and the  king with the basketball  dork trying to guard him lebron holding  it with seven to shoot  james still with it one bounce dribble  on its way  air ball and taken by okc they have a  chance to win it they will call a  timeout here  114 113 and the thunder  have the basketball with 4.3 left  in ot  [Applause]  [Laughter]  oh boy  [Applause]  lakers trying to i guess run the clock  down as  far as possible lebron has it in dort  it's region reaching and  well they're pretty good defense there  though he really did he forced him into  a  difficult attempt which obviously didn't  hit the rim and  they get possession now with 4.3 the  thunder a chance